what TV show would you most like to see
Tom Holland in okay I think one would
probably be Euphoria lots of people have
been talking about that two would be
Hawkeye maybe the Disney Plus show and
three I'm gonna go with the new Lord of
the Rings show
peaky blinders I actually auditioned for
peaky blinders and I did not get the
part oh euphoria's too okay well I got
that right I got that right what's
number one I bet it's too hot to handle
that would be so jokes if it is
I'm a celebrity get me out of here ah I
actually would love to do that
really yeah well that's obviously my
biggest fan what is naked attraction oh
it's that show dirty